los profesionales de la salud mexicanos
son los más afectados por la pandemia de
coronavirus hasta 1.320 trabajadores han
perdido la vida en su lucha contra el
virus de los más de 97 mil 600
contagiados estos son los datos más
altos del mundo que superan a los de
países como eeuu o brasil en méxico el
número oficial de muertes de personas
trabajadoras de la salud ha llegado a
las cifras sobrecogedora de 1.320
personas el 25 de agosto del ministerio
de salud de méxico confirmó 97 mil 632
casos de kobe 19 entre las personas
trabajadoras de la salud la causa los
constantes brotes en centros médicos
registrados por la falta de equipos
protectores incluso medio año después
del primer caso registrado esto se
siente especialmente en las provincias
pero estos no son los únicos datos
negativos que registra el país su tasa
de mortalidad con respecto a los
contagios es con diferencia la más alta
del mundo con 10,8 por ciento
prácticamente dobla a las cifras de
otros países como irán perú bolivia o
indonesia algo que desde el gobierno
justifican con la condición física de
los mexicanos pero
se puede deber a la falta de pruebas lo
que los datos nos dicen hasta el momento
y nos fueron los datos en méjico es que
las principales comorbilidades que
generan enfermedad grave y por lo tanto
defunciones en kobe de 19 al menos son
estos 3 sobrepeso y obesidad diabetes e
hipertensión y eso es algo que es una
prevalencia alta en la población
mexicana y por lo tanto también
contribuye definitivamente a los
resultados que hemos visto a pesar de
los datos méxico está en plena del
confinamiento desde hace meses un
movimiento que busca reactivar la
maltrecha economía pero que según las
cifras ha acelerado la pandemia